People will come up
to me and say, "Ugh!",
"If only I had heard
about this five years ago,
I wouldn't be
divorced right now."
Radical Candor is caring
personally and challenging
directly at the same time.
It all starts with
soliciting feedback.
Don't dish it out before
you prove you can take it.
I like to ask, "What could I do
or stop doing that would make
it easier to work with me?"
You will give
criticism and you'll
learn how to gauge how what
you're saying is landing.
Am I hearing you say that I
can be very "micromanage-y"?
Yeah.
OK.
You'll walk away
with a tool kit that
will help you navigate
even the toughest
conversations with confidence.